so as we get back into our long form
character discussions and the return of
Marvel request Monday I had jumped on
Periscope asking which character people
would be interested in seeing and The
Punisher was by and large the popular
choice now because Marvel request Monday
is a day where I hand my channel over to
you guys to determine the videos
regarding Marvel characters this week
we're going to be talking about Frank
Castle and so the Punisher first
appeared in Amazing Spider-Man issue
number 129 in 1974 and was created by
Jerry Conway with contributions from
Stanley and John Rita senior that
actually comes as Fallout from the death
of Gwen Stacy storyline what I mean here
is that following the night G Stacy died
story in Amazing Spider-Man issue number
121 and issue number 122 Peter had
sought his revenge against the Green
Goblin in a state of rage and when the
battle between the two took place Peter
had intended to kill Osborne but backed
off at the last minute however using his
Remote Control Glider Osborne had
intended to kill Peter by impaling him
but when Parker dodged at the last
minute Osborne was seemingly killed by
his own hack now where Osborne would
eventually return to the Marvel
landscape with the Revelation that he
had simply been regenerating the fact
remains that during this time of the
story the city of New York is under the
belief that Peter had killed Osborne as
such he's not really considered a
vigilante and instead operates on kind
of a strict leash regarding what it is
that he can and can't do now regarding
the creation of the Punisher because
Jerry Conway's story of the night when
Stacy died had catapulted him to the
level of Superstar status among comic
writers his success had placed him in a
position where he wrote for both DC and
Marvel as such the workload he endured
was massive in scale but in order to
ensure that his Creations were fleshed
out appropriately Conway often provided
primitive designs of what he wanted his
characters to look like to this end
during an interview as part of comic
reporter's article titled Spider-Man at
50 Conway had stated that the Punisher
was originally designed with a small
white skull on his left breast with John
Rita Senor expanding the design to the
full scope of punisher's chest in
addition to this Conway had originally
wanted Punisher to be referred to as the
assassin but because Stan Lee didn't see
a comic succeeding with that line of
thought due to the fact that it limited
the character's role within the Marvel
landscape the name was changed to
Punisher which provided a connotation
that would allow for Castle to switch
between the role of a villain and a
traditional hero but also walk the line
between both as an
anti-hero now in his first appearance
Frank Castle simply showed up with no
backstory provided regarding his
character instead punisher's first
appearance came with the introduction of
a villain called The Jackal while Miles
Warren had made his day previously with
Amazing Spider-Man number 31 in 1965 his
role was largely supportive in that he
had affections for Gwen Stacy but never
acted on them instead following her
death at the hands of the Green Goblin
and Spider-Man Warren came to believe
that Peter was responsible leading to
him undertaking his villainous mantle of
the Jackal and seeking Revenge however
regarding the Punisher his appearance
here doesn't come with any context
suffice it to say that he's simply
working with the Jackal although his
motives at the moment remain unknown and
so transitioning to Peter this portion
of the story serves to segue into his
everyday life in battling criminals but
also gives us some perspective of his
life with Gwenn Stacy having died
coupled with how the World Views him
because this point in Peter's career
still sees him funing his life by way of
taking pictures of himself battling
villains and selling them to Jameson
where he is successful in apprehending
the thieves and ending their scheme the
death of Green Goblin still takes center
stage and that the city as a whole views
Peter as a murderer now again we know
this isn't the case and that Osborne
died by his own hands but because the
Green Goblin was a villain and had
committed multiple heinous acts the city
didn't really mourn his loss and I would
argue that under the surface celebrated
the loss of Norman but at the same time
the citizens of New York weren't really
ready for one of their most celebrated
Heroes to become a perceived murderer at
this point we follow Peter to the Daily
Bugle as he turns his pictures over to J
Jonah Jameson at which point he gains
his first exposure to The Punisher
however rather than their first
encounter being a battle The Punisher is
introduced by way of Jameson who has
taken an interest in the Vigilante now
because the only available news on
Castle comes from the New York star
arriv rival newspaper of The Daily Bugle
the goal of Jameson is to have Peter
snag pictures of The Punisher and order
to ensure that the bugle stays relevant
among newspaper Publishers to this end
as Peter makes his way through New York
as Spider-Man his Spider Sense begins to
tingle with the Punisher simultaneously
taking aim with the intention of killing
Parker dodging the shot at the last
minute we learned that punisher's attack
came in the form of a concussive
projectile designed to incinerate Peter
traveling to its source what Marvel does
here is establish Punisher as somewhat
extremely capable in terms of his use of
weapons and martial arts but also
functioning under the same mindset as
most of New York's citizenry where
Peter's attempt to apprehend The
Punisher leads him to believe that
castle is trying to escape the truth is
revealed when Castle grabs a gun capable
of shooting titanium alloy wiring strong
enough to insens snare Peter even if
only temporarily in addition to this the
words of Frank Castle indicate that he's
under the impression that Peter is
indeed a murderer making the case that
he exists to fight and kill criminals
wherever he finds them like the citizens
of New York The Punisher believes Peter
to be a killer and intends to eliminate
him however the mistake the castle makes
here is underestimating Peter's strength
and that he fails to realize how strong
Peter truly is what I mean here is that
the titanium wiring was strong enough to
hold 10 men and immobilize them but
because Peter's strength is well beyond
that he's easily able to break free and
battle castle during this time we also
learn that Jackal has been monitoring
the fight between Spider-Man and
Punisher however Jackal looks to keep
his identity hidden while simultaneously
ensuring that Punisher is successful due
to the fact that if Peter gains the
upper hand Punisher May reveal the
existence of Warren as The Jackal with
Peter deducing the fact they've all been
tricked as such Warren steps in and
incapacitates Peter from behind using
his electrically charged claws allowing
both Jackal and Punisher the chance to
escape with both believing that Peter
had died during the fall from the
building now what Marvel does here is
tell us that neither Punisher nor Warren
know the full extent of Peter's
abilities and the Parker's able to block
out the pain of jackal's attack and use
his webbing to cling to a ledge and slow
his momentum pH by swinging into a
building now the reason why Punisher and
Warren know so little about his
character is that castle is presumed to
have only recently appeared on the scene
in Marvel Comics and Warren had
effectively been hidden away from the
world while developing his Jackal
Persona as a result both men only knew
of Spider-Man's capabilities by way of
whatever reports they happen to come
across as well as Jameson's articles in
the Daily Bugle and so with both men
believing Peter's dead they vacate the
scene leaving their various weapons and
Armament behind which Peter uses as
Clues to determine the true identities
of its attackers and why they're
pursuing him now following Peter's
investigation of these Clues the story
also sets the stage for Harry Osborne
undertaking the Green Goblin mantle well
this really isn't a relevant part of our
discussion at the very least it goes to
establishing a more well-rounded
discussion of the story because the
death of Norman sent Osborne Industries
into disarray leading to bankruptcy this
combined with Harry's breakup to Mary
Jane Watson led to a mental breakdown
pushing him over the limit and
eventually leading him to undertaking
the Green Goblin mantle but for the
purposes of this video we shift our
Focus back to the Punisher and Jackal
now what Conway does here is establish
that castle isn't necessarily a killer
for hire and instead has his own code of
honor this particular bit is of
significance since this will become a
mainstate of his character for the
duration of his role in Marvel Comics
but for Castle killing Peter Parker
isn't about revenge and instead is part
of his overarching goal to eliminate the
criminal element of New York as a whole
as such The Punisher begins to question
his partnership with Jackal as the
fundamental difference between their
motives regarding the death of Peter
comes down to the levels of Honor that
the two hold having said that the roads
of Peter and Castle eventually meet as
the two both set out to meet a man
called the mechanic to Sidetrack for a
second the mechanic was a man named rice
but he has an extremely minor role
within the realm of Marvel Comics where
writer Archie Goodwin would flesh out
Rice's backstory during Marvel super
action number one in 1976 as the former
ordinance man of Frank Castle during the
Vietnam war within the context of the
story from Spider-Man when both Peter
Parker and Punisher arrived to the
mechanics base of operations Peter
discovered that he's dead at the same
time that castle arrives the result is
that castle comes to the belief that
Peter had killed rice leading to another
battle between the two now during their
fight Peter attempts to reason with
Punisher by pointing out the damage on
Rice's neck and the fact that he was
killed by Jackal however because Castle
refuses to listen and is hellbent on the
idea that Peter is a murderer and needs
to be killed Parker is met with no other
choice but to knock castle out and so
with Punisher coming too a few minutes
later Peter's able to talk reason into
him with Punisher coming to the
realization that Jackal had killed his
friend an ally as such as the story
comes to a close the Punisher and
Spider-Man don't really become allies so
much as Punisher abandons his attempt to
kill Peter and instead turns his
attention to Jackal now following his
first appearance and while looking to
the newly established Marvel preview
series which was designed to Showcase
heroic Adventure Science Fiction and
sword and sorcery content Marvel hoped
to capitalize on the introduction of
Castle by creating a backstory that fed
into his anti-hero qualities that fans
enjoyed while making him relatable and
engender some measure of sympathy among
readers and so under Jerry Conway and
artist Tony desunia in 1975 the first
origin of Frank Castle was established
in the Marvel Universe in this story The
Punisher continues his quest of killing
various villains within the Marvel
Universe but his backstory is provided
by way of the efforts of a man named
Chief Inspector Hamilton after acquiring
the dossier on Frank Castle from the
United States Marine Corps as part of
his attempt to track Castle down and
stop his Madness we learn that the name
Punisher is actually derived from the
media which began calling Frank Castle
by that name due to his perceived
punishment of criminals who would
otherwise escape the justice system in
addition to this Castle had served in
the Vietnam War for two tours during
which time he was awarded the
Congressional Medal of Honor the highest
award the military and provided to
soldiers for going above and beyond the
Call of Duty the Bronze Star for Heroic
achievement the Silver Star for Valor
and the Purple Heart on four different
occasions for sustained injuries during
battle all of which goes towards
illustrating the Frank Castle had a gift
for success in combat in addition to
this Castle was slated to receive the
presidential medle of Freedom which is
given to civilians for cultural or other
significant public or private Endeavors
but it disappeared before this could
happen the reasoning is revealed when we
learned that sometime following his
service in the military Frank Castle and
his family had been caught in the
crossfire between two rival mobs because
Castle's family were considered
Witnesses the mob had killed his wife
and children while Frank was shot the
mob had believed him dead and in doing
so left the scene with no one left to
verify what had happened however because
Frank survived but discovered that his
family had been slaughtered his mind
snapped and in the process he waged a
war against all criminals everywhere
Ving to kill them regardless of their
reasons and
motivations so following his first
appearance in Marvel Comics as well as
his publication of his origin Punisher
became an instant hit and was an example
of a character who is in the right place
at the right time what I mean here is
that the Punisher was introduced as a
ground level anti-hero but also had a
backstory my and tragedy that provided
reasoning behind its actions and so
between February of 1975 and October of
1983 Castle appeared in 20 separate
Comics including a return in Amazing
Spider-Man issues 134 and 135 followed
up with issues 161 162 174 and 175 in
addition to Giant siiz Spider-Man number
four Captain America number 241
Daredevil issues 182 through 184 and
Spectacular Spider-Man issues 81 through
83 furthermore because his appearances
were in the cream of the crop regarding
Marvel's popular titles in January 1986
after 12 years of guest appearances in
various Publications Punisher received
his first solo series with a 5issue run
titled circle of blood written by Steve
Grant and misprinted as a 4issue series
The Circle of blood was a groundbreaking
story within the comic book industry
what I mean here is that while the death
of GW Stacy did see the incorporation of
Sidekicks and love interest dying in the
end Marvel was still very much in the
business of providing content deemed
familyfriendly or at the very least
appropriate for older children as such
during the years of Frank Miller's
Daredevil which pushed the limits of
acceptability by incorporating
references to off panel drug use and
pornography Marvel was unwilling to
throw the baby out with a bath water and
provide stories depicting or referencing
suicide sexual intercourse and the death
of children however in the minds of
writer Steve Grant and artist Mike Z The
Punisher was a rare opportunity for
Marvel to break the mold and try
something new the reason why was because
Castle's increased rise in popularity by
way of Frank Miller's landmarked child's
play storyline with Daredevil issues 182
through 184 which saw the death of
Electra me that the Punisher stood in a
murky area and whether by Marvel's
intention or not had the potential to
usher in stories providing content much
darker than what had been seen before
indeed the transition of real world
society from the lighter days of the
1960s into the darker days of the 1980s
by way of the Vietnam War the civil
rights movement and the second wave
feminist movement meant that people were
ready to see more realistic and gritty
content in addition to this Chris
Claremont had already built on Frank
Miller's idea of edgier concepts by
incorporating real world elements into
his X-Men stories like 1982's God loves
man kills which used the n-word and so
to Grant and Z if the Punisher were to
succeed as a viable title with Marvel
Comics instead of falling into the realm
of obscurity or else being turned into a
run-of-the-mill Hero Marvel needed to
allow Grant and Zac to throw everything
against the wall and let fans determine
what was deemed socially acceptable as a
result Marvel Grant and Z found a middle
ground with the duo being allowed to
create the content they were looking for
while Marvel released the comic without
any advertisement of its existence
allowing the company to remove it from
circulation without drawing attention if
fan reception was overly negative
centering on Castle being released from
Riker's Island prison and into the
custody of a group called The trust
which was composed of a group of
everyday people and modeled after
Castle's ideology of bringing vigilante
punishment to criminals the trust
differed in that they Incorporated the
brainwashing of other criminals into
carrying out their vigilante murders
however because the personal code of
Castle decrees the elimination of all
criminals while sparing the innocent the
philosophy of the trust in working with
criminals albeit through brainwashing
led him to come into direct conflict
with the group using darar devil born
again as a basis and that the Kingpin
existed as the king of crime and Hell's
Kitchen but whose reputation was
destroyed Frank Castle had lied to
reporter Ben Yurick by stating that he
had killed Wilson Fisk as a result the
entire criminal underworld fell into a
state of civil war with various gangs
and factions looking to fill the void
left by the perceived death of Kingpin
and consolidate the remaining power unto
themselves while this did achieve the
result that castle was looking for and
that he could sit back and quite
literally allow the criminals to kill
themselves at the same time it also
presented the issue of innocent people
dying in the crossfire and so after
weighing the two options and determining
that allowing criminals to exist and
killing them peace meal was a better
alternative to risking the lives of
innocence in their civil war castle
brings a conflict to an end and
eliminates the trust before going back
into his life of killing villains now
where Marvel had expressed concern over
the tastefulness of the story in that
issue number three saw the death of an
innocent young girl and issue number two
indic at that the Punisher had engaged
an intercourse with a woman named Angela
these concerns were assuaged when the
story received critical Acclaim and is
widely considered to be one of Punisher
best stories behind 2003's born and 2004
is in the beginning as a result the
following year in July of 1987 Marvel
launched an ongoing Punisher series
under writer Mike Baron as a fledgling
writer at the time providing content for
DC with the first 14 issues of Wally
West as The Flash coming out of crisis
on infinite Earth in June of 1987 Mike
Baron's early run on Punisher was
extremely well-received in that while it
lacked the borderline content of Grant
and ze's miniseries it continued the
anti-hero status of Punisher while
maintaining Castle's violent methods of
interrogating and killing criminals
where Baron had remained writer of the
series up until Issue Number 62 in 1992
the popularity of stories like the
six-part jigsaw puzzle led to the
introduction of the 1988 and 1992 Branch
off series title Punisher War Journal
and parnish a war zone respectively both
of which ran into their cancellations in
1995 furthermore between 19 1993 and
1994 in addition to Volume 2 war zone
and War Journal Castle was depicted in
three multi-part annual specials five
one shots four limited series and five
crossovers with Archie Spider-Man Batman
as well as Ghost Rider and wolver rain
now with Baron leaving the series after
Issue Number 62 writer Chuck Dixon was
brought on board with issue number 63's
Faceoff and continued many of the themes
from both Grant and Baron's runs with
the
character because Dixon's handling of
Castle continued to move the title in an
upward Direction regarding sales and po
ity albeit Among The Limited fan base
where his run on volume 2 was shortlived
this was due to Marvel moving him over
to launch war zone with Steve Grant Dan
Abnet and others taking over the writing
chores for the remainder of volume 2
however by 1995 where the punnish was
wildly popular among his smaller fan
base and had seen successful one-hot
Comics like Punisher Kills the Marvel
Universe his ongoing series had never
achieved the same level of success as
titles like Spider-Man the X-Men or even
Captain America as a result in the same
year Marvel canceled Volume 2 war zone
and War Journal and underwriter Dan
Abnet released the four-part series The
Punisher year 1 which served as an
unofficial reboot and focused on the
backstory of his character and Castle's
road to undertaking The Punisher mantle
now because the series sold so well
Marvel looked at testing the waters with
another ongoing series simply titled
Punisher an underwriter John Ender hoped
to provide a fresh take on the character
and Revitalize interest following the
slumping sales which had resulted in the
previous series cancellation in the end
though the attempt failed and after 18
issues the line was canceled and so
between 1996 and 1999 The Punisher was
resigned to several miniseries in guest
appearances in Marvel Comics including a
four-part Marvel night story titled
pergatory which has been widely
ridiculed by fans and critics alike for
its poor storytelling as well as 1999's
Crossover with wolver rain titled
Revelation so because of his slumping
popularity and lack of sales Marvel
hadn't quite given up hope on the
Punisher but his character was viewed as
kind of a no man's land and jumping off
platform for writers looking to move on
to bigger and better things during this
time and after riding for DC's
Constantine within the pages of
hellblazer in 2000 gu Andis had been
hired by Marvel editor and Chief Joe
cada to take over the Punisher series
beginning his run with a 12 issue story
arc titled welcome back Frank alongside
Steve Dylan and Jimmy palotti G inis
sought to effectively reboot the entire
series and start over from scratch
returning to the roots of Steve Grant
and Mike Z's miniseries which had made
the character so popular the welcome
back Frank story saw Punisher returning
to New York after a leave of absence and
cutting a swa through the criminal
underworld
considered by many to be one of the best
Punisher stories of all time welcome
back Frank revitalized interest in
Castle's character and in 2001 the
series was relaunched with volume 4
under innocent Dylan as part of the
Marvel Knights imprint now with Marvel
Knights The Punisher only lasting for
about 37 issues the cancellation of the
series did not come out of poor
reception for the character but actually
came out of how well the title was
received for fans of the Punisher as
well as both Innis and Dylan themselves
the reason why the Punisher had never
succeeded in Marvel Comics was because
of the fact that the type of of content
necessary for his success was contingent
on being able to provide grittier
stories that weren't seen in the main
Marvel lineup in truth the grand Z Min
series was ahead of its time and still
considered to be one of the best stories
but in order for Frank hastle to truly
come into his own Marvel needed a way to
provide stories on his character that
weren't Bound by the restrictions of age
appropriate material and so looking to
the success of Brian Michael benn's
Alias series and the introduction of
Jessica Jones in March of 2004 Marvel
rolled the Punisher over into a
standalone series of stories geared
towards ad readers renaming the comic to
Punisher MAX during his time as writer
and with lisis lorosa replacing Steve
Dylan as artist The Punisher MAX Line of
comics has become the definitive line of
Punisher stories due to the heavy
emphasis on character development and
simultaneous focus on the darker side of
the comic book Universe because inis
preferred to tell stories isolated from
the superpowered antics of individuals
like the Incredible Hulk or the cosmic
Opera and instead preferred street level
stories with a real world Edge his
writing style flourished with moments
like issue number 21's monologue
regarding Castle's temptation to kill
Innocents along with the guilty standing
out as some of the most memorable quotes
this combined with stories like the
six-part slavers Arc dealing with human
trafficking meant that Frank Castle had
quite literally found a solid home for
himself with a hardcore reader base at
the same time and in 2006 under writer
Matt fraction Marvel reintroduced the
parnish re War Journal Volume 2 to
coincide with Civil War in an effort to
beef up the continuing popularity of the
max imprint sales however by 2008 G inis
had Departed the Punisher MAX Line to
help Marvel launch a re incarnation of
the Phantom eagle from the 1970s Wars
hell stories looking to the positive
reception of Matt fraction's writing due
to War Journal and the possibility of
releasing another solo series outside of
Marvel Max the War Journal line was
renamed a Punisher with RI Remer taking
control of the title where issues 1
through1 and Punisher annual number one
served to provide Frank Castle's
perspective in the post Civil War and
secret Invasion leadup to dark Reign
which saw Norman Osborne taking over
Shield following Stark's ousting in
disgrace Remer had wrote a one-hot
titled the list which saw Punisher faing
ing off against Wolverine's son daon and
dying in the process following this
issues 11- 21 saw Frank Castle return as
a frankenstein-like monster fighting on
behalf of Marvel's underworld monsters
against an army of Samurai while the
post dark rain stories were largely
considered silly fans viewed the concept
as a well-received break for Marvel's
constant attempts to re-energize
interest in a method of Storytelling
that had long since become uninteresting
however this reprieve proved itself to
be brief when the end of Franken Castle
saw Punisher return to his normal human
self after which the was relaunched yet
again under the writing of Greg Rucka
having previously worked alongside Jeff
John's and Jud Winnick during the
countdown to Infinite Crisis as well as
DC's 52 alongside Grant Morrison and
Mark Wade Greg Rucker was brought in as
writer for The Punisher series due to
Rick Remer departing in order to launch
uncanny xforce while rucka's run of
Punisher received strong reviews for its
return to focusing almost exclusively on
castle and away from the actions of
other superheroes in the Marvel Universe
like so many writers before him Rucka
was unable to reinvigorate enough
interest in the series to keep fans
intrigued resulting in the series
cancellation in 2012 after only 16
issues and so with Marvel laying the
groundwork for their secret Wars event
by way of Jonathan Hickman's Avengers
and New Avengers under Nathan Edmonson
The Punisher was relaunched with volume
9 in
2014 moving Frank castle out of New York
and sending him to Los Angeles the
intention of Marvel was not to create an
ongoing series but instead set the stage
for sending the character of Frank
Castle out on a high note and that when
the final incursion took place between
Earth 616 and the Ultimate Universe The
Punisher was finally able to see his
goal of killing all criminals by quite
literally entering the Kingpin into the
world celebration and slaughtering
everyone and so with marel relaunching
their continuity with all neww all
different Marvel Post Secret Wars while
we have not seen a title regarding the
Punisher character or his introduction
into this new universe because John BNF
fall will be appearing in Daredevil
season 2 as The Punisher it stands for
reason that most likely we'll see his
return in some manner even if only in a
miniseries
format with that being said we're going
to bring this video to an end and let me
know in the comments section which
character you want to see for Marvel
Comics next week and I will catch you
guys later
peace